-We're back with Paul Giamatti.
You play a teacher in the film.
Your mom was a teacher.
Your father was an academic
who was president of Yale.
Did you ever consider
going into academia yourself?
-Briefly.
It was a little bit of a thing.
It was like the family
business a little bit.
So it went through your head,
but I was like, "I'm not cut out
to be a teacher at all."
I'd be a terrible teacher.
-Well, you're a very
you're a very good one
on screen.
-Thank you.
-That's a nice outcome.
So you do have a podcast where
you co-host with a professor.
-I do.
-So I think that's as close
as maybe you'd want to get.
-Yes.
And he's a very -- he's not --
he's a philosophy professor,
but he's also a professional
blues guitar player.
He's a very unusual guy.
-How did you meet him?
How did you connect with...?
-He was he was giving
a talk online
about sort of this kind of
weird brain consciousness
and the use of psychedelics
and therapy and stuff.
And of course, I tuned in
to that and I'm like --
and I'm like,
"This is interesting."
[ Applause ]
-And I -- [ Laughs ] Really.
Yeah! Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
And so -- And I thought,
"This guy's really interesting."
So I got in touch
with him afterwards.
And he was a little bit
like, "Who is this really?
Is this really Paul Giamatti?"
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-And I was like, "Who would
pretend to be me to try...?"
I mean, like,
why would anybody go,
"I need to disguise
myself as that guy.
Oh, yeah. The guy from..."
-It's funny that the way --
the reason you disguise yourself
as Paul Giamatti
is to meet a professor.
-[ Laughs ] Exactly!
-Like, who the professors like?
-Yeah, exactly! Exactly.
Oh, I guess that makes sense,
actually, now that you say it.
Aha.
-He's like, "You're like
the third Giamatti
who's called me today."
-[ Laughs ]
But we hit it off really well.
-And how quickly
after hitting it off
did you realize
"we should do a podcast..."
-A while, actually.
-Okay.
-We were just having
conversations all the time,
and it was during
all the COVID stuff.
And he was in Chicago
and I was out here,
and so we were just on Zoom,
and we'd just have
these long conversations.
And then he was like,
"Maybe we should do this
in front of people."
And I was like, "Okay.
Okay, professor."
And so we did,
and it's been really fun
and we wanted to animate it,
originally.
-Yeah.
-Thing to be animated.
He had a student.
He teaches at an arts college.
He had a student
named Alex Sokol,
who is a brilliant animator.
Couldn't do the whole thing.
It was too expensive.
-Right, 'cause
they're an hour long. Right.
-It's too much.
So it was like we have little
bits of it get animated.
-Yes. So if you --
if you listen to it
and watch it online,
like watch it on YouTube,
all of a sudden
there's like these
really nice animations.
-They're fantastic.
-It's really good.
-Yes.
-This is a real reminder
that this started
with psychedelic drugs.
-I was going to say.
I was going to remind you.
Alex has clearly taken
some therapeutic psychedelics.
-It's really --
It's really wonderful.
-Yeah, and the idea is it's
a very free-form conversation
and you start off
with sort of unusual topics.
You get into,
like, UFOs and Sasquatch
and, you know,
and it's freeing for me
because I'd reached a point
where I thought,
"I'm tired of not talking
about Sasquatch."
-Yeah. Because you
obviously have a lot to say.
-[ Laughs ]
I have a lot to say.
-But it is a weird thing
to bring up at a dinner party.
-Yes, it is.
-But on a podcast,
the perfect place to start
talking about Sasquatch.
And where are you
on Sasquatch?
Are you pro?
You think he's out there?
-I do think there might be
something out there.
-Okay, great.
-And Stephen really thinks
there might be
something out there.
-That's great.
And then does that --
Do I assume that he's also --
believes that UFOs...?
-Yes,
he's a little bit more skeptical
for some reason about UFOs.
-So funny.
-Which makes no sense.
-I feel like there's way more
data on UFOs than Sasquatch.
-I agree, but he actually -- I
think he thinks that sort of
from a zoological point of view
there could be a kind
of species of monkey
that we haven't
really discovered.
-Okay.
-Which happens.
It does happen.
-That does happen.
-It's this kind of exciting
stuff you tune in for, folks.
-What about ghosts?
Where is he --
-Ghosts. Ghosts.
I 100% believe in ghosts.
He tends to be more skeptical --
except about Sasquatch --
than I am.
I believe more kind of --
-It's really funny for a guy
to be like, "UFOs aren't real.
Ghosts aren't real.
But Sasquatch, 100%."
-[ Laughs ]
-"And I'm going to catch him.
I'll be the one."
-That's exactly what it's like.
And sometimes we talk to,
like, an ancient historian
of ancient Egypt.
We talk to
a professional psychic.
We talked to Kathryn Hahn.
We talked to all kinds of --
-It's a nice mix.
It's a really fun mix.
-It's a really good mix.
-So I have to ask you this
just because
of the timing of this.
So this week,
my wife and I were like,
"We have to watch something
where we can just, like,
enjoy it,
shut off our brains."
It's a very fraught time
in the world.
-Uh-huh.
-And so we've been watching
old rom-coms.
-Ah, nice.
-And we watched
"My Best Friend's Wedding,"
and then all of a sudden,
Giamatti turns up in the hallway
with Julia Roberts.
You're the bellman.
How early --
How early in the career?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Just look at the --
look at the head of hair.
Look at the head of hair.
-Yeah.
-That was pretty early on
in my -- in my career
as a -- as a film actor.
I hadn't done much film at all,
no.
I didn't know what
this movie was about. Nothing.
They just hired me
and gave me this scene.
I did audition for it.
They gave me the scene.
I didn't know what
the movie was about. Nothing.
-It is really
like peak Julia Roberts.
Like, you just watch it
and you're like,
"Oh, my God, this..."
I mean, she's still wonderful,
but like movie star
Julia Roberts.
And I would imagine it's just
the two of you in the scene.
Is it one where
a little bit of nerves?
-Oh, yeah. No, I was
very nervous, but she was...
Oh, yeah. I didn't really know
what I was doing on film.
-Yeah.
-She was incredibly cool.
And I remember the first time
I met her,
she was sort of going
through her handbag
and looking for some gum
or something.
They introduced me to her,
and she was kind of...
She turned around,
she had that smile,
and I was like, "Holy [bleep]."
[ Laughter ]
I was like, "That's why
this person is who they are."
It was just amazing.
-You realize -- You're like,
"Yep, everybody got it right."
-Yep.
-"This was supposed to happen,
and we're very lucky to be here
to witness it."
-She should be doing this.
-Yeah.
Well,
congratulations on the film.
Thank you for bringing
our attention to the podcast.
-Thanks. Thank you so much.
-It's always the best
to have you.
You guys, that's Paul Giamatti.
He's the best.
"Chinwag" is available
on YouTube
and wherever you listen
to your podcasts.
"The Holdovers" is in theaters
now nationwide.
Be right back with Andrew Moskos
and "Pep" Rosenfeld.